majestueuse et imposante en plein centre
bourg l'église saint-pierre de chambon
semble indestructible
pourtant le temps qui passe grignote
lapierre et fatigue l'édifice témoin de
cette usure le portail de style roman
vous voyez l'état des pierres qui se
dégradent vraiment les pierres ont été
faites en les travaux en 1995 et depuis
elle commence gentiment à s'effriter et
là ça devient de pire en pire à
l'intérieur même constat des fissures
immense envahissent les murs l'eau
s'infiltre par endroits le plâtre
s'écroule et dans la sacristie les
parois semble s'affaisser autant
d'éléments qui inquiète les habitants de
chambon habitués à célébrer mariages
baptêmes et enterrements dans cette
église elle est importante parce qu'elle
est classée aux monuments historiques
donc c'est une église qui datent de 11
122 et qui donc est magnifique de par sa
porte et c'est vrai que c'est que c'est
le patrimoine du village donc c'est vrai
qu'on y tient énormément une petite
élise et pour préserver cet ouvrage
propriété de la mairie une association
de sauvegarde a été créé le but récolter
au minimum 150 mille euros pour réaliser
les travaux urgents une somme trop
importante pour le petit budget de la
commune même si celle ci prévoit de tout
faire pour trouver des aides et rénover
l'édifice
il faut pas se mettre de barrières on
aura des portes qui se ferment euros
mais il faut quand même les entrouvrir
et ça permettra aussi à un moment donné
de faire connaître chambon donc oui on
ira se battent partout
l'association elle prévoit d'organiser
plusieurs événements tout au long de
l'année pour récolter des fonds une
brocante aura d'ailleurs lieu ce
dimanche pour lancer la collecte